Hello and welcome back to Paragliding Atlas Podcast.
I'm your host, Aninder Singh, and joining us today is the man
who needs no introduction. I'm talking about none other
than Russell Ogden. Russ, how do I begin?
This is beyond words. Such a huge honour and something
that I'd looked forward to ever since I started flying.
Thank you so much for coming. Well, thank you so long to be
here and looking forward to it, Russ.
I've been in the sport for like almost 7-8 years now and you
know, one thing that I've always kind of sought after is
information. And as I do, I of course, you
know, look it up on the public domain, on the Internet and
whatever search engines provide us.
I'm very curious, are you the most interviewed person in
paragliding? I have no idea.
I have absolutely no idea. I have been on YouTube and
podcast quite a few times. So much of what I've said is has
been said many times before and heard many times before.
And a lot of my friends actually say, oh God, not him again.
Because yeah, it's all been said and heard before.
But it's, it's good to be here with you.
It's been a while actually since I've done.
You know, as I was researching for the show, I was trying to,
uh, I mean, of course I've binged on every single piece of
information that you've put out there, but I was looking up and
these days search engines are switching to AI and everything
is like you, you talk to the bots and they respond.
And I was like, the amount of information that Russ has put
out through various mediums, It's like there can be a single
section like Russ Ogden Paragliding Encyclopaedia itself
with the with this knowledge that kind of has been generated
over the past years or so. Yeah.
Well, I think it's really important that we, you know,
knowledge is key in this sport. And I think it's really
important that there's a there's a free spread of information to
to make the sport as so that we all have as much information as
possible. It's so, so important.
And especially when we're at the sharp end sort of working as and
it's, I'm happy and glad to be able to share it.
And I, I always classify myself as second generation pilot.
By the time I started flying, there was an established
training regime in the UK. The BHPA had had a complete
training schedule. And so I was very much part of
the second generation and I and when I started, I looked up to
the first generation pilots, the guys that were flying the 9
cells and slowly evolving to more higher performance wings.
But by the time I first started flying, we already had high
performing paragliders that look like paragliders we fly today
rather than old parachutes. So I think I got into the sport
at just the right time. The point that I was trying to
get to was that I do remember you, you speaking in one of your
shows that you knew from day one that this was for you.
What I'm wondering is that did you kind of envision a life of
where you are at now that you'll be spearheading, let's say the
R&D and one of the foremost players in the industry
impacting so many other paragliding pilots lives by that
and of course, you know, sharing the joy with the community and
everybody else around you? No, I didn't aspire to do that
and I'm not sure if I even do that right now.
But I was teaching paragliding for 10 years and I really
enjoyed teaching paragliding and I thought that's probably what I
would remain doing. But now I work, you know, as, as
a test pilot for ozone. Just a very small role, a small
part in a in a big machine that is ozone and I, I play but a
small role in that. One thing that I've kind of seen
from you every time like you have interacted with someone is
that you, you come across as a very humble person.
Is there something that you have kind of done right, which you
have noticed, of course, besides your personality and, you know,
just being humble in itself that is kind of made you that way,
But still, is there something that helped you stay like that
and kind of come across as an approachable and easy to talk
to? No, I just, I, I guess I think
humility is a British value and also I've never seen it as I've
never seen myself as anything special in the world's of, of
pilots. Everything I've achieved and,
and acquired is by hard work and practice and a lot of steady
progression. I, I, I was, you know, it took,
it took years to, to kind of get to any reasonable level for me.
I wasn't, I wasn't necessarily the fastest learner or the OR,
or progressed so fast. But back then there wasn't the
information. It was really difficult to, you
know, progress fast because everything we were doing was, we
were learning as we went. You know, we didn't have him.
Nowadays you see the kids come along 1617 and they're doing
infinite tumbles and all of these things and, and they've
only been flying a few years. And when I look back at how it
was in the 90s, I mean, there was no charge.
We were, we were doing wing overs, you know, and even then
they were radical and, and the wings we had, the equipment we
had wasn't quite as up to the standards that they have now.
But I think, I think knowledge is key there.
And nowadays you can, you can get, there's so much sources of
information and there's so many good instructors that can guide
pilots through. I mean, we had good instructors
back in the 90s that knew their stuff, but it was the blind
leading the blind because the, the, the, the local sky gods had
100 hours, you know, and 100 hours, it's like, my God,
they're so experienced. Whereas nowadays 100 hours
doesn't really mean a great deal.
So yeah, we've progressed a long way.
Yeah, I mean hard work does kind of shape your personality up to
a point as well. But like the the reason why I
asked that question is I want to know a little bit of ideology of
gratitude because gratitude can mitigate a lot of lot of, I
wouldn't say negative feelings, but like feelings which you
don't want to have at a certain stage.
And I think maybe listeners can resonate to this, that quite a
few times when you land from a flight which hasn't gone the way
you wanted it to be, you are not really in the right mindset.
Regardless of the the fact that you are one of the lucky few who
get to fly a machine called Paraglider in the world out of
everyone else, you know that's here on the planet.
And this can be applied in cross country context or even
especially in competition if you bomb out.
Or you know, when you compare yourself as humans to others and
comparison is the root of all evil, but somehow we all end up
doing it. So how do you navigate the
formal or feelings which come with those kind of after
effects? I think that's the the hardest
part to deal with really is disappointment in paradigm
competitions. But I think it's the same in any
sport, if any, any sport that you do professionally.
I think, you know, learning to lose, learning to learning to
not achieve what you expect and being able to deal with that is
a really important process because that's how you learn and
how you grow. And paragliding is a whole world
of paragliding competitions. Is, is is mostly disappointment.
And if you don't deal with that disappointment very well, then
you you don't last very long as a competition pilot.
And from when I first started flying, I knew I was in it for
the long run. So I was not really, I wasn't
aiming to for a quick fix. I I wanted to be able to do this
for my adult life and, and, and get enjoyment from it.
And, and I'm learning to deal with your defeats is just
crucial, just crucial to paragliding.
I grew up playing quite a bit of golf and I still play golf and
that's very much a a similar sport.
I love golf, but I, I know I've, but I've never walked away from
a golf course thinking that was a brilliant.
I've always walked away thinking that was a bit disappointing
because I missed this and I missed that and and so on.
So golf was a good level for me and a good a good sport to kind
of give you the right mindset to, to to compete with.
I I read somewhere that you have to let emotions come as well,
and that is a part of being human.
And I'd like to take the example of, let's say Roger Federer is
one of the all time greats in tennis and Maxim Pino is on,
like you can say on a similar level, the way he chases
excellence in our sport. Both of them, the reason why I'm
comparing them right now is that Roger Federer said that there
was a stage in life when he was quite used to throwing away the
rackets and the tantrums on a coat until one day he just
decided that enough is enough and he has to change his
personality because he's throwing away his matches.
I remember speaking to Maxime because he has been on the show
as well earlier. And I think this was PwC
Krochevo last year when he bombed out in day two.
He was leading as usual. And then he probably went too
aggressive and then took the first retrieve bus back to the
hotel. And I asked him, I was like, are
you dealing with it fine? And he was like, yeah, yeah, I
was. And I said how?
And like, what's, what's your thought process?
And he said, like, I have thrown quite a few helmets in my back
in the day, but now I've kind of gotten over it.
So is it more or less like a process that you cannot force of
calming down and learning to deal with your defeats?
Or is it a conscious effort that the sooner you do, the better it
is? Because in the end, you're the
only one who's entering a self destruct mode when you do that.
Nobody else is paying the price for your happiness or for your
defeats. Yeah, for me, it's a conscious
effort. Yeah, totally.
I mean, we've all, we've all done it.
I mean, I remember the the one time after, you know, I think it
was my first World Championships many years ago.
And I've actually flown my personal best.
I've flown 150 something kilometres, but I only just
short of the goal and my gloves went in One Direction, the other
glove in another direction, helmet thrown one way.
And, and it was that moment where in that landing field
where I had a word with myself and I thought, come on, Russ,
what's that? You know, you've just done the
best flight, the furthest flight you've ever done and you're
still in one piece. You're an amazing place.
You're, you're privileged, like you said earlier, you know,
we're very privileged to be able to do what we do.
And I realised I was making a big scene over absolutely
nothing. And so since that day, I, I, I
have never thrown another helmet or glove anywhere.
But you still get, I hate bombing out.
We have to hate bombing out. If you hate bombing out, when
you, you learn strategies and decision processes that avoid
bombing out. But I still do it.
I, I, I bombed out badly last year in, in Macedonia, in
Krishova as well on the last day of a comp, which I think I was
winning on the last day or I was close to the top anyway
somewhere. And I completely blew the comp.
But you know, I allow myself a couple of minutes to be pissed
off and then there's no point in carrying on with that mindset.
So I just let it go. You just have to let it go.
And I think once you've heard enough disappointment in life,
you can let it go much easier. I think as you get older and
more mature as a pilot, not necessarily just in age, but
just in whatever you're doing, you've, you've had it, you've
had bad, you know, we've all bombed out and we'll all bombed
out again in the future. And as long as you have that
mindset and think of the long run rather than just a very
short run, then it allows you to kind of deal with it better and
I think you'll find the best pilots in the world deal with it
quite well. Does it come to some, like
somewhere to the levels of testosterone we have in our
body? I mean, I cannot speak the same
for female pilots, but as you age it does gradually decrease.
And of course your drive, your anger, your a lot of other
things change physically in human body.
So does it have a bigger role to play as well?
I think it probably does. I think that, you know, the hot
headed ones of normally then their 20s, only 20s and they,
you know, they want to, they want to come, they want to come
onto the scene and prove a point and, and the, and the the pain
of not achieving is, is is harder for them.
I think, you know, like you're talking about Maxine was a bit
that way when he was younger, Otto was, but now they've been
through that process, They've won, they've lost, they've won
again, they've lost again. They've been through this cycle.
And at the end of the day, it doesn't, it doesn't really
matter. And I think as long as you, you,
you keep that in the front of your mind, but it, it doesn't
really matter. You know, as long as you land
safely and you're not broken, then it's not so bad.
And so I think a bit of maturity certainly helps with that.
I think about testosterone, but I think maturity is, is the is
what helps deal with that because I think you have to be
competitive to, to do well. But if you're too competitive,
you're going out too quickly. And those sort of pilots, they,
I've seen them come and go, but they don't really stick around a
huge amount of time, I don't think.
Please correct me if I'm wrong, but I do remember a statement.
I don't know where I heard it, but someone said that you
mentioned paraglider pilots tend to peak around the age of 30
years in their lifetime, let's say.
Is that more or less the sweet spot when you have enough
aggression slash experience and you know you're able to navigate
the risk versus reward spectrum responsibly?
Or is there like more to that statement which people don't
know yet? I think, I think it's to do with
experience. I think experience is, is just
the king in, in competitive paragliding.
We see young guys come along and I'd take Oh no.
And, and Maxime is a great example.
They they came on the scene at roughly the same time and they
were roughly the same age. I think they were early 20s when
they started competing at the top level and they were the two
young matadors, you know, the, the, the hot shots coming in and
they wanted to prove a point. And on their day they did prove
a point. They proved that they could
attack and win tasks. But it took them a while before
they started winning competitions and it took a while
before they started winning competitions regularly.
And I think I've seen with most pilots that come along, myself
included, is that yeah, mid 30s or after flying for 15 years,
something like that is when you kind of peek and reach your your
best. And I think for me, I started
flying when I was 21 and I was probably peeking at the best
that I've flown in my mid to late 30s.
And when I look at other pilots coming through now like
Sebastian Ospina, he's really peaking right now and he's of
that age. Ono has been.
Ono, I rate is the best pilot that we've had in our
generation. Nobody has dominated the sport
like he has. He had something like 15 podiums
in a row. And that's podiums, a good level
comps, That's World Cups, that's European Championships, World
Championships and French championships.
It's not, you know, it's not beginner comps at all.
And that's that's an insane statistic that is it hasn't been
touched in our generation and I don't think it will be for
another while. It's a very hard one to
maintain. So yeah, no, I think, I think
we, it takes 15 years. You you though we can, it takes
15 years of competing to be able to be at your best.
I'd say that way you just generate so much experience and
it becomes a little bit more hard wired into your decision
making process because you know we've all made the mistakes,
you've made all the mistakes there is to be made.
You continue to make those mistakes, but you you minimize
the amount of time you make the mistakes.
Just to provide a reference point for the listeners,
approximately how many hours per year in those 15 minutes are an
average should a pilot look for? How many hours you've got to fly
as much as you can. I mean, life gets in the way.
There's people with jobs, lives, families, but you, you, I, I
think you need to be flying. You should be aiming at 100
hours a year, be able to, to fly and to be able to do 3 or 4,
four competitions a year is, is, is a, quite a healthy way to
progress. But even if you do, yeah, you're
looking at 10 competitions before you start to really get
get better. And let's say test pilots, I'm,
I'm not sure how Connor and like Baptiste or someone of that
stature does, but are they clocking in like 4-5 hundred
every year? Is is that the level of
experience that the elites are having?
Yeah, but Oh no. And I, we fly around about 500
hours a year, I think. No, I'll know a bit more than me
because he does more competitions.
But you know, our testing work is something like that.
Yeah, we're, we're, we're flying every day.
It's flyable pretty much. And we get, we put a lot of time
in the saddle, definitely. What a life, Ross.
I want to. I want to talk about pacing it
out because I believe holding back is very important.
Burnouts are real. Everyone faces.
Everyone is a human. Yeah, like everybody is has to
process their emotions. But there is something that
differentiates the great from the good, and hard work is
probably the only answer. Talent only goes so far.
So you want to be a great pilot? You want to go out and.
Make it count where it matters the most.
For example, 15 podiums in a row is one of the reference points.
You know the amount of drive he must have had.
And I can let this know to the listeners that Honoren was one
of the first guests on the show. If you're keen, just Scroll down
the menu. You will listen to his episode
gem of a production. It's a tell all tale on how he
made it and what he really kind of what his essence is in
flying. But let's say to keep it, to
keep it within your limits. And I, I, I love the way you put
it, that it's to keep the lust going.
How do you how do you not overdo something that you're obsessed
with They're. Not well, I'm not doing it too
much. I think this is something I've
been very conscious of in the last, well probably the last
1520 years I've only done 3 competitions a year, 4
competitions maximum. Every now and then I did a year
of five competitions, but most of the time I'm not competing
that much because if I if I take too many competitions, I start
to get a bit bored a bit and annoyed a bit.
Whereas whereas just doing a few comps a year keeps it fresh and
exciting. And, but I think when you're
starting out, you have to go through the process and do as
much as you physically can. And those pilots that do that
can dedicate that much time and do that many comps, you see
their progression going the fastest.
And I think in Paradigm, it's relatively easy to get to a good
level. I mean, it's not like tennis
where you could play tennis solidly for three years but you
could never have a game with Federer.
Whereas if you dedicated to paragliding, you can go out
there and go head to head with honour.
You probably won't win, but you will.
You can give him a good run for his money.
So paragliding is good for that. You know, lots that you don't
need to be ultra talented physically or mentally to be
able to do well. And we see lots of pilots get
good. There's lots of good pilots in
the world right now. The hardest step is the last
step. The hardest step is is into is
to become a great pilot. And I think that is once you get
to that level, it's it's more of a mental thing.
Then it's your mindset and how you think and how you expect to
Keith, how you expect to finish, how you expect to do well.
And I think you know, someone like Ono will just he he expects
to win every competition he flies and he flies in a way to
win that competition every now and then, you know, it messes up
and he'll he'll have a bad come. But if you always go in with
that winning mindset, you're more likely to achieve and do
well. But it's, we talk about sports
psychology quite a lot in paragliding.
And I've always said that it's, it's something that you can only
really use once you've had results.
You can only if you've never had a good result, you can't think
yourself to be a better pilot. But once you have good results,
once you have great flights, for example, you can, you can always
bring yourself back into that mindset to try and to try and
put yourself in the right mindset to be able to perform
the the best you can. I'm thinking from, let's say, I
wouldn't say a beginner, but let's say an intermediate.
You, you got like 50 to 200 hours under your belt.
You can't stop thinking about it.
You're more or less obsessing over racing or, you know, just
chasing the glory as hard as you can.
You tend to overlook a lot of things when you're rushing.
Of course rushing is not advisable.
But let's say if you as a pilot are rushing, is there a Safeway
to rush where you can mitigate the risks better because you
just want to be there so damn bad?
I don't think there's any shortcuts or safe ways to rush
in power building. No, but I don't think there is.
I mean, you can. You can do it as much as you
can, but always, you know, you, you, you soon become the, your,
your, your. The biggest danger to yourself,
and it's something I talk a lot about when we're at work is, you
know, for, especially for Ono and I, who we fly every day, all
day, every day. The biggest danger is, is us and
the decisions we make as to when to fly or when not to fly
because you can, you can get overconfident really easily.
And we all know all the experienced pilots know that you
know, they're when there's, when you meet, when you're flying in
conditions where there's dust devils and things like this
going on, you've got to be, you shouldn't be flying.
And I, so I think for intermediate pilots, I saw one
the other day we were flying. It was an amazing day here at
Cordon and really good strong thermals, quite a bit of wind
and there was a big a beginner up there really struggling and
there was only Ondo and I flying.
It was really strong conditions and the beginner pilot was up
flying with us so he had no control whatsoever and it was
just quite worrying to see really that people when you're
in that very keen, lustful part of your flying career is where
you have to be able to recognise that and you have to be able to
self regulate, especially the conditions you flying.
I'm sorry I lost my thought process for a second.
I had such a big question coming up but shit I.
Hope I answered the last one. I hope I answered the last one.
Sorry. You can you can cut edit this
out. I have to, I have to.
I can't bring this What? Jesus, I had such a huge thought
process coming out, but let me let me just recompose.
This happens in flying as well when you lose the thermal as
well, right? Yeah, yeah, yes.
Russ, I remember hearing you talk about the G experience
because I think that is one thing that I can relate
personally. What's the G experience?
The G Force experience because I, I can relate to it personally
and you I, I wouldn't call it rushing, but I would definitely
say skipping a step. I was I was a 90 hour pilot and
I had flown an Ena until then and I was like OK, I'm finally
ready. But I was flying the Himalayas
beer billing where it it can get quite punchy, quite rough.
And I just upgraded to a high BI think 9th or 10th flight.
So it was like less than 5 or 6 hours with that wing.
Got an asymmetric and went into double twisted auto rotation.
Until then I hadn't done an SIV because somehow it hadn't come
in my life by then. But when that circular motion
was pulling me down, the forces were so overwhelming that I'm
more or less froze. If I'm completely honest, the
glider was very powerful, violent, angry, and it just
seemed that no matter how much energy I put, how much strength
I had, it did not want to move. So I deployed fairly high.
I think I was like almost 2000 meter above ground level.
So I was at an altitude like 4 or 5000.
But what I'm what I'm coming to is that the G forces are such a
huge probability when you're flying an aircraft like a
paraglider, how often or like how important is it to keep your
G tolerance? First of all, be aware of it and
secondly, develop it, because I think the more you do it, the
more Peace of Mind you have. I could say that.
Yeah, I think from what I've read about G tolerance is that
we all have a slightly different G tolerance and it's nothing
really to do with physical fitness or anything like that.
It just depends on your own body.
I think we can train it and I see it on a daily basis where
some days I'm super strong and I've got amazing tolerance and
other days I'm losing vision without having a great deal of
G. So I think we vary depending on
on the day, depending on the hydration or or other factors,
but it's definitely something you need to be aware of.
When I used to teach SIVI used to want to always introduce
pilots to G quite early on in the course because I wanted the
pilots themselves to understand their own G tolerance.
Because if you know your own G tolerance, you can can avoid
going past the limit. Because if you're, especially if
you're, you know you, your decision to throw your reserve
up high was probably excellent because had you held on for much
longer, you start to lose your vision and then you can't see
anything. And within a couple of seconds
of not being able to see anything, you're gone and you
black out. And that's so getting your
reserve out before you lose your vision is is normally a very
wise thing to do. But let's say SIVS are very
controlled environment and of course, you know, they only come
or the opportunity to do an SIV only comes to you that often,
depending upon wherever you're learning or whatever ecosystem
you, you're flying in as a as as a recreational or the semi, you
know, experienced pilot, can you just go out?
I mean, of course 2 liners or anything beyond will go out of
trim if you practice spirals pretty often.
But E and A&E and B wings low B. I'm, I'm talking about like
beginner intermediate lighters. Is it healthy enough to just go
out and do this every once in a while to test test the waters
yourself within your limits and not doing anything crazy?
Yeah, I think it is. I think if you, if you know your
G tolerance, if you've done a spiral bibes on an SOB course or
under a controlled environment within the instructor, if you
have altitude, then I, I, I see them as quite as a relatively
safe means of practice practicing your G tolerance.
And you can develop your flying skills to try and, you know,
generate, get the wing nose down and then exit without too much
energy. And then so it teaches you and
you can learn how to control the energy of, of the wing so that
it's not pitching and surging all over the base when you exit.
So I think it's with altitude, it's a, it's a reasonably safe
thing to do as so long as you know your G force limits and so
long as you know your wing as well.
Because I nearly, I nearly died very early in my flying career,
In fact, from a spiral dive where I've done a few spiral
dives. And whenever I've done a spiral
dive, the glider just recovered as soon as I put my hand up.
And so the one one day I decided to try and do one down, down a
little bit lower to the ground on a wing I hadn't flown before.
And I put my hand up to exit the spiral and nothing happened.
And I ended up obviously weight shifting away and breaking away,
which fortunately for me was an instinctive process to do.
And I ended up practically doing the ground spiral.
But I just about got away with discovering my first experience
of a neutral spiral. And I've never even heard of a
neutral spiral back then. Whereas nowadays it's a bit more
common knowledge. And I think it's always wise to
to go into these things knowing as much as you can and knowing
just expect as as long as you, you go in with the mindset that
every time you do a spiral dive, it's going to remain neutral.
And if you go in with that mindset, then you are always
ready to opposite weight shift, opposite brake to pull it out as
a habit in testing, when we're testing new wings and I'm
testing spiral dive, I will only spiral to the right.
And the reason I do only spiral dives to the right hand side is
so that if I do lose my vision and I start to become
disorientated, I know I've got to pull left to exit and I will
always have to only pull left to exit.
So when I'm testing I I I only have a spiral dive to the right.
Just out of curiosity. I have.
I think I felt this myself. Keeping on spirals to one single
direction repeatedly is more likely to put your wing out of
tune in one way. Because I I did feel my wing.
No, definitely yeah. No, definitely yeah.
I mean, ideally you wanna you wanna fiery or glider equal
amounts in both directions, especially for the the race
horses, for the for the comp wings for the two liners.
What in fact, all modern wings, all modern wings, because back
in the day, you know, everything had two 100K line everywhere,
300K line everywhere, big thick ropes.
Whereas now we're optimised everything, even down onto E&B
wings, the the optimised line sets.
And so they and the sale, the constructions of the sale isn't
quite as strong as it used to be.
Maybe so you can stretch out or win quite easily if you
repeatedly spiral it in the same direction.
So I recommend to always do equal sides I.
Want to come back to the kit point after this one.
But Russ, first of all, thank you for mentioning your
experience. I'm pretty sure, like I don't
know if this is like a jinx or something that once you get a
bike, you do crash, you know, at least once before you learn how
to ride properly And like para lighter as well that once you
really start pushing it, you do end up, you know, what is it
like the analogy that some pilots have landed in a tree and
some pilots are yet to land in a tree or something like that?
But like the question that I'm very curious is that how to
process fear the right way? Because I remember when I was
walking away from that deployment, endless questions
were coming in my mind. And one of them was that why the
hell can't I fly a hang glider when all I'm chasing is the art
of flight and a rigid wing is more safer than a collapsible
wing. And of course, you know, there
was a whole list of thoughts that I eventually wrote down and
I processed it and then I kind of made peace with with them.
And that's why I kind of got got back on the horse when I was
comfortable. But what is your way of
processing fear every time something which was outside your
comfort zone happens? I think, I think with time you
develop a kind of fear tolerance.
I guess early in my flying career I had, there was times
where I'd take off and I'd be petrified and I would, I would,
yeah, have irrational fear. And I knew it was irrational,
but I didn't have enough experience and confidence in
myself to really fully understand it.
So, so you, you become fearful because you're, we're, we're all
fearful of the unknown. And it was partly because of
that experience. And that I, you know, I really
decided early on, I really wanted to just understand as
much as I can about paragliders and, and the way they fly and,
and, and how they react when they're not flying.
So I could overcome those irrational fears.
But I think it's a normal process.
And I think, you know, all of us who fly, we've all felt fear.
And if you haven't felt fear, then you probably will feel,
feel fear in the future or you should have a word with yourself
because what we do is so unnatural.
We're in environment where we're just not meant to be.
And when you're, until you've been exposed to for long enough
in those environments, fear is a really normal process.
So if you do suffer fear, it's not because you're deficient in
any way, it's because you're perfectly normal.
How you deal with fear is by and with knowledge and with
experience you can overcome fear.
And I think having hours in the saddle training as much as
possible, going to SIV to control courses, pilot
progression courses, all of these things allows you to, to
deal with fear in a better way. And I think for me, for example,
when I did, I, I very distinct memories of when I did my first
ever SIV course and I was, I was crapping myself.
I was shitting myself. I was with Jockey and I don't
even really remember my first SIV course because all I was
worried about was how I was going to react.
I wasn't really listening to Jockey about exactly what to do
because I was just worried. I was just hoping I wasn't going
to freeze. And it was only my second or
third SIV course. I actually started learning
because by which time I had enough confidence to know that
I'm, I wasn't going to freeze and I wasn't going to react
badly. So I think as you learn yourself
and how you react and how you are and how you react to extreme
situations, that's when the fear can start to, to come down.
But we're dealing with fear on date on on a daily basis as test
pilots, you know, it's something that we we have to go through
and we and we continually go through.
You know, it's never, it's you never get particularly
comfortable pulling full speed collapses on comp wings.
It's not something that is ever you can get comfortable with,
but you can get, you can just by repeating and doing and doing
and doing just it becomes easier.
But me, when I first started as a test pilot, fear even I was a
reasonably competent pilot when I started, but fear was a big
part of the first couple of years.
As you're learning and as soon as you've, you've learnt more
and your, your skill set has increased, then the fear starts
to subside more. And the, and the less fear you
have, the more fun you have. So for me, the, the fun curve in
paragliding went up after 200 hours because I had less fear.
That curve still continues. I'd feel it's a really good
thing because like now, for example, when I get scared in
the air now there's a real reason for it.
And I really listen to myself when I'm scared in the air now
because when I get scared in the air now, it's either because
there's an issue with the wing that I'm flying or.
Normally because the conditions are just too strong or I put
myself in a rubbish place or done made a stupid decision, you
know, but it's, it's hard when you're learning to be able to
recognise irrational or to be able to distinguish between
irrational fear and and, and genuine fear, real fear.
OK. That, that is a very interesting
point that you made there, that there are some unknowns which
only experience tells you. And you know, that is how you
see the light of the day. But I want to talk about inner
voice a little bit here because to me, inner voice is something
that always exists. And that is like you cannot lie
to yourself deep down. You can, you can, you can put on
a mask, you can show a personality on the outside.
But when it comes to knowing your true self and I can give an
example of myself over here, you know, like tomorrow it looks
flyable in Oslo. And I want to go and slide this
take off, which is my absolute favorite.
It's right in the city, allows me to see the cityscape.
One of the most beautiful flights I have every time.
However, I haven't been there for the past six months.
I'm considering taking a wing that I haven't flown for the
past six months because I was flying something else and my
reserves aren't repacked for more than six months.
So there are quite a few. I mean, I wouldn't say red
flags, but quite a few red lines that I feel that I'm
overstepping, which is causing me to rethink and saying that,
hey, why can't you put in an effort and go to a take off,
which is an hour away, which has got a bit more leeway.
But again, the, the pull towards this one is somehow making me
still make that choice. So deep down, if I'm honest with
myself, it's like my inner voice is being ignored due to which
the fear is coming. So can this more or less be
applied in a lot of situations if you're brutally honest with
yourself? Because you will know what
you're doing eventually? Yeah, but you're, you're, you're
the duality. I think as it's known, is, is
really important. But sometimes your inner voice
is, is, is not right. Sometimes it's incorrect.
Sometimes it's irrational. Often the irrational thoughts
come from from that voice, though.
I, I think you have to, you have to know thyself, don't you?
I mean, for me personally, and I've always had this in the
matter, especially paragliding, is I've always been really
progressive with everything I've done and I've never tried to
step too fast too soon. I've been probably a little bit
too slow in my progression in that sense.
I, I've flown for years, but I've done 4 or 500 hours before
I flew an E&D type wing, a high performance wing.
You know, I did my time on intermediate.
So I I progressed relatively slowly, but I think your inner
voice is something that you should certainly listen to, but
accept that sometimes it is also wrong as well.
But there's always a fine line in paragliding between
aggression and pushing yourself and making yourself a better
pilot and holding yourself back too much so that you don't
really progress at the rate that you want to do so.
I think being brutally honest with yourself is, is is
essential. I think in in any sport, in any
extreme sport and paradigm is a really dangerous sport.
And I think is if you acknowledge that, then you'll be
able to make better decisions as you go forward.
Right. That's such a good way to put
that. Because I think for anybody
who's wondering, just just hit the rewind button and listen to
it all over again. That was like pure wisdom, you
know, when it comes to listening to your inner voice and
processing fear. But Russ, while, while we're
talking about the the kit and like a little bit of this, I
want to quickly touch upon the topic of maintenance or let's
say repacking or stuff like that.
And there's enough wisdom out there which a lot of people will
know. We don't have to spend a lot of
time on it, but not repacking your kit, your reserve
periodically. The only danger is that it might
take longer opening times. Or is there more to that
statement? I don't know, I'm not an expert
in this subject, so I can't really comment a huge amount.
I've certainly been, I think, I don't think I've ever repacked
my parachute on the six month process.
I think it's it's, it's a little bit longer and I think it
depends on the environment. It depends on whether you've had
to, to get the harness wet. It depends on static electricity
as well, because static can hold the wings.
We've seen enough with, there's been enough cases over the years
of parachutes that have been packed, squashed and unpacked
for years that didn't open properly.
So I, I, I think to mitigate those risks, having your
parachute packed at least on an annual basis, is, is a wise
thing to, to, to do, yeah. Did did you say that they have
been? They had been stayed packed for
quite a while and then repacked and then did not perform on upon
deployment. No, normally it's when they've
been packed for a long time. They can, especially if moisture
gets in there or any static energy.
It's static electricity. Anything like that can keep keep
it closed. But I'm not an expert on that
subject so I can't. I don't feel like I'm really in
a place to comment. You need to speak to someone who
packs lots of reserves and does lots of practice deployments in
the line. Actually.
It's not something I've done a huge amount.
We've had an episode with URS Hari like he's probably gonna be
given the credit. Right he's the man yeah yeah,
he's the man yeah. Yeah.
So I'll I'll to whatever he says because I'm not so cool I.
Was going to say that episode with him has been the most
listened to episode and it's on the top of the list in Spotify.
So anybody who's listening, just go to the Spotify episode index
and you'll see, oh, sorry, gem of production.
You know, the I, I honestly never knew there were so many
secrets that existed with the parachutes because manuals only
tell you so much until you hear from the guru himself.
So that was quite insightful. Yeah.
Oh, I need to. I need to listen to that one
then definitely. Right, right.
But Russ, this is another you can say a psychological question
because this this is definitely a mental thing.
I would say. I was just wondering when I
moved to a Western society, one thing that I saw that everything
was super new. You know, I've grown up in Asia,
I've grown up in a developing country and I'm not used to
seeing extravagant amounts of expenditure on daily usage
things. Quality of life is very
different in, in, in different parts of the world.
And usually when you live in a Western European country,
especially somewhere like Norway, you see you, you get
used to like your new normal becomes fairly of a high
standard. And of course the same thing.
So with the gliders as well that back in, in Asia, you, you, you
would see gliders which are a bit dirty.
I mean, of course, some of that can be credited to the
environmental conditions that it's, it's dusty and everything,
but people tend to use their wings a lot more there than what
I've seen in, in, in these economies.
So what like the question that was coming to my mind was that a
lot of times people say that or, or you see people buying new
clothes or, you know, having these latest fashion on them.
And it has become a statement of self-confidence that it, it, it
helps you walk more upright. It helps you bring out your,
your, your best self outside. Does the same kind of relate to
the kit in paragliding up to a point?
Because a lot of us are more than happy investing in
equipment that we don't really need because it looks flashy and
it looks like it's the latest story on the market and stuff
like that. So how does how does spending
make you feel better? Or does it actually make you fly
better? Yeah, I think, I think it's, I
think, I think we've seen so much progression in paragliding
equipment over the last few years, well over the last 15
years. I would say that there were real
tangible benefits for upgrading your equipment to get a small
percentage of additional performance because a small
percentage of additional performance can actually give
large amounts of it opens the world to a lot more
possibilities with flying, you know, just a few percentage more
performance in your wing can get exponentially more when you're
trying to fly across country. When I left, I have a similar
experience to you because I came from a third world country, a
developing country into into the first world.
When I left the UK and and moved to France and when I left the UK
we had the the 100 kilometre club was quite exclusive.
And now that same club, now the exclusive club is the 300
kilometre club. And we haven't improved
performance free fold. We've only added, you know, a
certain percentage, a small percentage of performance over
the years, but that just makes flying long distance way more
feasible and possible. So I think if you can fly a
modern wing and when I say modern something within six
years old, you are going to have access to, to pretty top notch
performance in paragliding harness wise.
I think you know, the submarine type harness do give additional
performance, but they're certainly really relevant to
competition flying or serious cross country flying.
You can still bang out a 300 kilometre flight on a any
standard called harness. You don't need anything special
like that. I think what's different with
with paragliders is that they, they can't, they, they do age
obviously and the performance and their safety goes down with
age. And so there's no reason.
I mean, I totally understand it in certain places where it's
financially more restrictive, but there's no point in flying
wings until they're they become unworthy.
There's just no point in doing that.
You may as well just keep good modern equipment that that will
keep you safe. I'm so glad you mentioned the
the submarine example because I've been very curious about one
thing. I'm not sure who I was having a
chat with but I think when you guys came out with the early
protos of submarine I heard the story that Honoren was smoking
people on enzos and conventional harness when he was flying a
Zeno plus a sub combination. So of course the pilot's skill
were, you know, top notch and yet he was able to squeeze in
every last bit of performance from a Xeno, which was eclipsing
the Enzo's. So when I heard that I was like,
of course, just like any other pilot, I was very keen to
upgrade to the flashiest tech available on the market.
But since it came with a bit of a trade off in back protection,
I stuck to the XO seat type harness that I fly with.
Does upgrading for minimum performance gain really make a
difference when you are not landing within the 1st 25 to 50
pilots in a PwC? Or is it just a psychological
thing that everyone is flying the flashiest twice so I have to
be there as well? No, I think it's, I think it's
not really of value. I, I, I see very good pilots who
don't fly submarines doing very well in competitions.
The speed and efficiency is borne by decision making.
It's not borne by the equipment that you use.
You could go to an any average competition.
Powell Takax kind of proved that point in the SRS when he won
flying a rush, an E&B wing. And so no, your speed and
efficiency is borne by decisions, not the equipment you
fly. For sure if you want to, if you
want to compete at the top level, then obviously you need
to be on on the on the right equipment and have it set
correctly. But if you just want to if you
want to roll up to APWC and finish in the top 20, you don't
have to do that. No, you have just have to make
good decisions and fly well throughout the week for a top 20
finish. If you want to start getting
near the podium or top ten then maybe you need the best.
But no you can. You can finish very well in the
PwC on a Zeno and a non submarine heart.
Damn that's so nice to hear because I think a lot of people
love the marketing gimmick and up to a point I think in in a
capitalist society it does mess with your head.
But that is where self-control and everything else comes, that
you face the reality rather than just getting carried away and
then make responsible decisions. Yeah, well, it is exciting as
well, isn't it? It's exciting to have new
equipment. It's exciting to have the best
equipment. It's exciting and it's great.
It's great. We're in a position now when I
first started competing, you couldn't compete against the
factory pilots because they had the prototypes, they had the
special equipment that wasn't accessible to all.
One of the beautiful things that's happened in our sport in
the last 15 years, really, yeah, 15 years, is that you can.
Now we have access to all the same equipment that the factory
pilots have and that's levelled the playing field somewhat and
and made it possible for any dedicated experienced pilot to
compete at the top level, at the best level.
I was actually going to come to the manufacturer's point anyway.
So I'm glad we are talking about this Like paragliding is an
industry that has evolved. I would, I would say rapidly up
to a point, you know, like free flight has kind of gone on in
leaps and bounds when it comes to convenience and performance.
And you know, putting all those parameters and any, any fast
growing industry requires everyone to keep up pace to
survive. A lot of times we have seen
niche industries are more or less like one man, one man LED
army where the the inventors, the founders are the ones who
are spearheading and as soon as they start fading, the the
creation kind of starts to fade with them.
A lot of brands have come and gone.
A lot of good ones have come, done their bit and moved on.
But legacy brands are there for a reason.
And Ozone has remained, I wouldn't just say relevant, but
like at the forefront of pushing the limits, setting the new
state of school and redefining what's possible next.
Is there a short answer to how did you guys do it?
Like if there's an aspiring brand listening to this.
I think, I think it's a combination of the work ethic
that we have in ozone. Ozone from from early when I
first started, the work ethic was very strong.
We had very high standards for ourselves and we always were
looking to to make the best things that we possibly can.
But I think the major, the major force behind the our success in
competitions is Luke Carmel. We, when, when Luke joined the,
the company, he bought a level of knowledge and understanding
and a thought process that has allowed us to maintain that
level at the top. And so I think there's, I think
we have a lot of thanks for the, for the work that Luke has done
and the, the, the, the ethic and the, the way we think about
processing the thoughts of progression is, is very much
down to him. But he's been backed.
What, what, what what's been good with Ozone is that, you
know, especially when in the early days, he was backed by
design by David, who had experience, and also by the
bosses of Ozone who almost gave free reign and, you know, the
ability to, yeah, go try this, do that, try that, do that.
We weren't held back by from above.
So it's, it's a little bit different now because the cost
of everything, the cost of prototypes has gone up so much
that we are not, we're not quite as free rein as we once were,
but we've, we've certainly kept the philosophy that it's always
good to innovate. We're, you know, we've, we're,
we're an R&D company and we aim to keep innovating and we've
innovative in, in different ways in different areas.
You know, Luke, Luke gave us the, the competition side, the
high performance side. But we've also we're very proud
of the, the work we've done in the lightweight equipment.
For example, you know when and that goes back from when David
first did the X Alps, we made a high performance lightweight
wing and from when we made the ultra light series down to the
extra extra light, which is where we made the first single
surface wing. So NF lights harness that was
under was 100 grams. So we, we, we concentrate on
being first and foremost an R&B company and we invest a lot in
the team, the R&D team. We've we've enlarged recently,
we've taken on more brain power. And so there's a good design
base of engineers working for Ozone right now.
And much of this focus recently is going into harnesses, and we
will see better harnesses in the future as well.
I'm very curious about your founding members because like
Robbie Whittle only has, you know, so much like Internet
presence. But every time he speaks, I I
feel like there's a lot of passion behind his thoughts.
And, you know, the way he conveys the way he talks about
like it's, it's just fascinating to hear him talk about flying.
And I really wish to have him on the show as well, because that
is like beyond words, something that I've envisioned as well,
just like you. But I'm, I'm just wondering,
monetizing your passion is, I think, the biggest blessing that
exists on this planet because somehow you are able to make
sense of your reality and be happy with it and always have
something to look forward to. Do you have some advice for
people who are looking to monetize their passion in this
industry, considering that you you are a part of one of the
most successful teams that exists on this planet?
I think. I think the one fundamental
thing you have to have is just a deep love for, for flying.
And that deep love changes as you, as, as you, as you grow and
as you age. And it, you know, you go, I've
talked about it before in the past where it's, it's like a
marriage. You know, you have this lustful
first few years and then it fades and, and then it turns
into a deeper love. So I, I, I see.
Well, I always go back to my marriage analogy with, with
flights. It's certainly been that way for
me. And and Rob's a good example
that you that you bring up. When I joined Ozone, the reason
I joined Ozone was because Rob wanted to stop testing.
And he said to me, he said, he said, Russ, yeah, I'm done with
it. I don't want to test anymore.
And I remember being at that stage in my flight.
I've been flying 10 years, but I couldn't empathise with what he
was saying. I just couldn't understand how
he could be in a position where he didn't want to continue
flying or pesting or developing. It's, I couldn't, I couldn't
relate to it at all. And it's, it's only recently
that I kind of, yeah, I understand where he's at now.
Because once you've done it enough and you've scratched your
itch, you've, you've got rid of that just absolute need to, to
fly. Yeah, in other factors, other
things in life become, come to the fore and become more
important. David de Gaulle, the guy who I
work with, he, you know, he's an amazing pilot, super talented
test pilot, designer and who taught me how to test.
And I worked with him when I first joined Ozone and recently
he's kind of stopped flying. He stopped testing and and flies
just very occasionally for fun at the weekends with on a tandem
with some friends. But otherwise his passions is
important. What he wants to do in his spare
time have gone have gone elsewhere.
So I think it's a normal process.
Rob's much the same. Rob went into kites.
He's actually coming back to paragliding quite now and he
would make a fantastic guest. You should get him on
definitely, because he's got very broad life experience and
stories and he's a super cool guy, so definitely worth having
him on. But I think this, to maintain a
long, long career in flying, you have to have a very, very deep
love of flying. I think that's the core
teaching. Paragliding is another thing.
I think most, most paragliding instructors have 10 years in
them, and after 10 years they become jaded.
They've said it all before. They've been through the whole
process before, and they lose that spark that made them a good
instructor five years previously.
I certainly was was was that case.
I was a reasonably OK instructor in my mid 20s.
By the time I stopped teaching, I probably wasn't as good as I
was before. Because you just become a bit
annoyed with it, you know, because you're talking about
flying much more than you are actually flying.
So it's hard to have a long career in paragliding because
it's hard to, it's a small, it's a difficult business, a
difficult industry to work in because you're, you're not
working, you're working with people who are your friends and
everybody knows everybody. And it's difficult to do
business with friends you know especially well.
You'll find out when you do. Guiding means that you'll get
repeat customers, repeat customers who become friends and
then you don't want to charge them as much as you did before.
And it all, it's a difficult industry to work in really.
Like I've always thought, but I've not.
It's the only industry I've ever worked in.
There's something about it which is inexplainable.
And in case the audiences are wondering, the the mention about
guiding that Russ said, as I think I've said it in a previous
couple of shows that we are working out on bringing the most
exotic paragliding tours on the planet to you guys.
So stay tuned, stay excited. It's it's a very nice project
that I can't wait to share with you all.
But coming back to the show, Russ, I'm so glad you mentioned
about teaching. You know, this is this is
something that has bothered me. Maybe would be the right kind of
a word is that passing on the baton is a very important skill
in anyone's life. You have to identify before it
starts becoming counterproductive.
And this is so true for teaching.
I have come across so many instructors.
I don't mean to badmouth anyone, but if you are reducing your own
quality of imparting what you love the most, then you're doing
injustice to the system. First of all, how to identify
that the stage has come, and secondly, how to convince
yourself that you have to make it happen otherwise you're
hitting the axe on your own foot kind of a thing.
Yeah, I mean, it's hard to, it's hard to identify, but we've all
seen those instructors and we see them regularly.
You know, they, they've been teaching too long and it's
become part of their life and what they do.
But they, they don't really give it the same energy that they
did, you know, a few years previous.
I definitely saw it with myself teaching.
I taught SIV for a long time as well and I could see it
happening in SIV as well. And it got to a point where it's
like, OK, you know, that's it's, it's a good time to stop, quit
while we were ahead. And half's on the batten to
people who are rated younger and motivated and wanting to, to do
that. So I think you just have to be
brutally honest with yourself and also accept that there is a,
you know, there is a finite time for these things to be at their
best. But no, it's, it's hard to walk
away from when you've been doing it for a while.
Definitely, definitely. And I do still miss teaching SRB
every now and then. Not a great deal, but a little
bit. Can the success of Ozone be also
contributed to the fact that the founding members did eventually
pass on the button when it was the right time?
Like in that sense. Oh well.
But the guys who started the company is still very much there
and they're still very much involved with it.
Mike Kavanaugh is the CEO. David Pilkington was the was in
charge of our production. We have a, we have our own
factory in Vietnam and he was responsible for for setting all
that up and getting that things going.
He lived out there for many, many years before he came back
to the UK, went back to the UK. So they're still involved with
the day-to-day running, but they have let go.
You know, Mike used to be in control of every little bit of
ozone and now he's let it go. But he could only let that go
once the company had reached a certain level.
And now we have a management team and, and it's a very
different company now than it was when I joined.
But, but, you know, change is the only certainty in life and
growth is, is really important. So now we're a, we're a much
bigger company. There's more of us.
People do specialist, more specialist roles.
And change is good. Change is necessary and to stay
at the top now you need to be innovative and you need to be
able to make good product. You know, we're only as good as
our last wing that we make and you can't rest on your laurels.
We've seen it with other manufacturers come and go and I
think there was a period, there was a period where it seemed
like we're seeing it now with harness manufacturers.
In fact, there's a few harness manufacturers just popping up
making boutique submarines and things like that.
And, and I think that's really hard for someone to maintain for
a long time. Because if you're if you're, if
you want to start a paragliding company, it's relatively easy.
You just get some software and you can send off your designs to
a factory and they can send you prototypes.
It's not that hard, but the work that goes on behind a product to
get it to market with the marketing, the photos, the
websites, the stock management, the order systems, it's, it's,
it's a, it's a massive endeavour.
And I think it's becoming more and more difficult to be able to
do that as a one man show than it was 20 years ago.
And I think now the the, the industry is maturing in a way
that there's a lot of good established companies making
good products right now. Right now we're in a really good
position in the paragliding world where we've got a choice,
a big choice of very good wings and harm seasons.
You know, there's a lot of innovative divide designers out
there. So we're in a healthy position
at the moment, I think like the industry as a whole.
I'm glad you mentioned change is the only constant because that
kind of I every time I think about evolution of wings as
well. And I, you know, I'm diverting
from the topic a bit here, but from open class to triple C and
now CSC, the civil sports class, there has been noise around the
change from both, you know, like sides which say this is good,
this is not. But somehow a lot of times I
personally feel that when excellence is basically
limitless, right? That is the way you can excel in
something when you truly chase it in a limitless manner.
Are we changing for the good or are we changing just because
change is the only constant? Very good question, I think.
I think the whole, the whole process of what we've seen over
the last years, you know, over the 15 years where we went away
from open class into CCC and now into sport class competitions,
CCFC and the whole debate that's gone on recently about
harnesses, protection and the like.
For me, it's a line drawing exercise and by which I mean we
all have a line and my line will possibly be different than yours
and my line is different than my wife's and my line is very
different than my mother's. And so where we draw this line,
where do we say what is acceptable, what is better, what
is worse? Where we draw that line is.
And I think the reason, you know, the utterings that's been
going on in the the pilot union and, and all of that movement
just shows how we all have slightly different lines.
Where we decide to draw that line I think is a really
personal opinion. What is nice is that we're
creating categories where people can fly comfortably in the
within the lines that they draw for themselves.
So I think we're moving in the right direction and we're moving
for the better. But there's part of me that
still arcs back a little bit towards the open class days.
There was, there was a beauty of the open class and, but I think
the reduction of the top speed for the CCC has, has, has led to
a real improvement in safety coupled with a big improvement
in pilot skill as well and pilot understanding.
I used to, I remember the first few PWC's you'd go to years ago,
you, you, you'd see someone take a 50% collapse and end up
throwing their reserve and it all seemed a bit futile and
pointless. Whereas nowadays I think
people's base level is much higher blighted control.
So we see less reserve deployments, our top speed is
reduced, our gliders are a little bit more stable.
So I think, I think the last 10 years, the last decade has been,
has been the heyday of paragliding competitions.
Right now, paragliding competitions have been more
popular than than they ever have been in or since I've been
flying. Although change is good,
sometimes you have to accept that actually what we have or
what we had was a really good thing, you know, and for sure
there's always ways that we can improve.
There's always ways that we can make it safer.
But often does that make it better?
I don't know. I don't know.
I think that's where we all have our own individual limit and
line. But any, any movement in the
world in the, in the for safety is good.
But it, it has its limits, doesn't it?
I mean, it has its limits where and how far we go with the
rules. For example, for example, the
CCC rule was, was really good in its day and it did its job,
which for me was let's limit top speed.
We, we, we, we have to go slower because the wings were so on
edge when they blew out at 70 odd kilometres an hour, it was
always missing. So getting rid of trimmers and
getting reducing top speed, I think did a really good thing
for, for, for pilot safety. But as you know, as Luke has so
eloquently pointed out in in in the interview with you and, and
then in many other discussions, is that those limits and those
rules have created a point where, OK, this is the profile
that you need to get the maximum speed out of 14 centimetres of
travel. And if we want to improve
stability, then we have to reduce top speed.
We can only improve stability by being and maintain the same top
speed for that stability by increasing the speed range.
So it's although we want to make more stable wings given the
given the rules that we have at the moment, if we were to do so,
we would have less top speed, which would make us not
competitive. So the current rules are forcing
designers into kind of 1 optimal kind of design.
And I think that's why Luke and others are pushing to, to change
the, the, the limiter, the 14 centimetres limiter because that
allows to go to, to more stable profiles.
Their stable profiles is, is something that we're moving
towards and we have done for the last 15 years.
And when we first in the old days of paragliding, you know,
we, we have quite highly cambered profiles and we needed
it to overcome all the drag that we had.
We also had really flat arcs and a combination of high camber and
flat arc made super aggressive behaviour post collapse.
And they also weren't very resistant to collapse, but
that's what was required to be able to not land at the bottom
of the hill back in the early 90s.
As we've evolved, as performance has got better, as drag has
reduced, the arc has increased, which is helped for post
collapse behaviour, cycle collapse behaviour.
And it's allowed for more stable profiles as well.
But everything you know, has has has its limits with within the
current rules. I think I think we all agree,
like you were saying earlier, you know, when you after you
threw your reserve, you're like, oh, why don't a family hang
glider that doesn't collapse? And we've all dreamt of, you
know, the paraglider that doesn't collapse.
And modern designers are kind of going more in this direction to
try and make stronger profiles, more collapse resistance,
because we believe that is safer and it is safer.
I'd much prefer to fly a wing that didn't collapse the one
that did. But we're still, we still have
to work within the realms of certification which favours
wings that are easy to collapse rather than wings that are
difficult to collapse. So I think we, we're in a
process now where I think in the next 1520 years we'll see some
more reasonable, I'd like to say radical, but I don't think the
WG Six group, which, which made the rules for certification are
a radical bunch. So I think we'll, I think we'll
see changes in the future to the certification process to make it
easier for stronger profile wins to get through.
Zillion points that I want to diverge to, but before I want to
go, let's say Will Gad mentioned because I've had him on the show
in the early days as well. Another gem of a production.
He said the ones who make the change, who will make the change
are the ones who go and challenge the the status quo and
you know, are like the gung ho about it and stuff like that.
So it's the minority that will eventually push us towards
getting out of a comfort zone to make sure that we are heading
forward and not stagnating ourselves or slipping backwards.
When I saw two liner E&C's coming out, yes, they were
serving very well to the racing community.
But when you compare the racing community to the majority of
consumers in paragliding, there are only a handful of pilots.
I thought we were doing a huge disservice to every single
intermediate pilot that had the option of going from a lobby to
a three liner ENC because suddenly three liner Encs were
not that lucrative anymore. So when we are allowing a small
minority to make the change for when it comes to ENC class, why
aren't we letting the same thought process push or
spearhead at the open or triple C levels?
Because there we want to pull back, but here we want to push
forward. So it kind of baffles to me that
are the ones at the helm making certain decisions which are in
like hidden interests. I don't want to rub across
anyone in a bad way but it just seems commercial market
viability be at the forefront of such busy working rather than
the safe or like the fun factor. Well, I just want to push back
on how, whether you consider because I, I totally understand
when when 2 liner encs came on the market and everyone thinks,
oh, we're pushing in the wrong direction.
But you just need to think about the previous generation or
especially the generation of wins that was previous to to the
to the generation that was superseded by the two liners and
some of those wings. You could look at the leading
edge and it would collapse at full speed.
They were they were trimmed in such a way that they were
designed for certification. They worked well in calm air,
but as soon as you're pushing along a Ridge in the mountains,
they they're not very interesting to fly because they
were collapsing all the time. You had to constantly fly active
coming off the bar on the bar with your legs.
And it was a very evolving, very demanding wing to fly.
And then everyone thinks it's two liner, it's two liner, it's
difficult, it's dangerous. It's it's much harder, but and,
but that's not the case. I think what you find now with
two liners is that they're easier to fly for an experienced
pilot. They're easier, less demanding
to fly than the old generation 3 liner Encs.
They're inherently more stable because the profiles got a bit
less CM in it, a bit more CM in it.
Sorry. And not only that, but they're
easier to control because you've got the wing in your hands at
all time and you've got direct angle of attack control with the
B risers. So to me it was a no brainer.
To me, it's it's an improvement in every way.
And I think now if you speak to a lot of the guys that were
maybe a bit more reluctant to begin with, they're very, very
happy. I think that the success of the
SRS series and that that level of wing is, is testament to
that. You know, we, we, we were also
cautious as well. We released the LP, we, we re
we, we remodelled the Alpena 4 so that we, we also offered a
three liner E&C wing out there as well.
But I don't think there was a very successful product.
Most pilots who fly E&C have moved over to the, the more the
two liners these days because it's a win, win situation.
I think for me, the, the, for me, the perfect balance is, is
low aspect ratio and to line of control.
To me, that's just like what we should all be flying and where
we should all go eventually, where all experienced pilots
should probably end up flying. Because the fact that we can use
collapse lines makes it mean that we can use profiles that
are slightly stronger. So they're, they're inherently
more stable profiles. They're less likely to collapse.
That can also you can trim them in a way that actually makes
them a little bit more comfortable as well.
And because you've got the the bees, you've always got control
of the wing no matter what speed you're going at.
So I think that was a real step forward in both performance and
in safety for experienced pilots.
Feel free to correct me if I'm wrong.
Russ experienced pilot versus the majority which is a weakened
flyer. Is my dilemma correct or is it
just in my head that we are catering to the ones who are
pushing the limits? And if that is the case, then
why did we ban open class? No, I don't think we are
catering to those pushing the limits.
I think we've always been and the whole, you know, the, the,
the political organisations behind paragliding the WG 6, the
PMI, the, the national governing bodies, they've, they've always
moved and done everything that's in the best for the majority of
the majority of their pilots. And the majority of the pilots
are weekend pilots. If I look, if I think about the,
the UK flying community, which is, which is on closest to, you
know, there's a lot of experienced pilots there.
They may be only flying at the weekends, but they they form the
majority of the the pilot base, the beginners and the
intermediates are a slightly smaller proportion.
They probably make up probably 45% of that group.
And we and WG 6, which is, which is the organization that makes
the rules for the EN testing. They're very much aware of this
and that's why we keep the Ena and the ENB in very simple three
liner type wings that we can't use collapse lines with.
But the the irony of that is that the two liners are now more
stable than the beginner wings. A beginner wing is more likely
to collapse in turbulent air than a high performance wing if
with no input. So we're in a situation where
beginner low airtime pilots have to fly the inherently less
stable wings than the more experienced pilots.
But that's just the nature of the certification procedures at
the moment and the rules that we currently have.
I had Michael Nessler on the show as well.
He had come out with, I wouldn't say like truly 2 liner, but he
had found a way to put collapse. Yeah.
Yeah, so 2 liner B, of course, it's very enticing, you know, to
any pilot who wants to push the limits and kind of go about it.
And as a designer, he did his own thing to quench his
curiosity. But is 2 liner is like like what
is a trade off if A2 liner A comes on the market or is, is
that a fair bit of evolution that the industry will go
towards? Because yeah, you, you keep on
pushing the flight envelope as the year's progress, more or
less. At the moment, I think the one
thing we can't cheat, I mean, two line, three line, 4 line, it
doesn't matter. We were having these same
discussions when we went from four line to three line years
ago, you know, exactly the same discussion that we're having
when we went from three line to two line.
I think what's what, what we don't, what we can't limit is
aspect ratio. Aspect ratio is the main factor
that defines the behaviour and the demand on the pilot in
terminal here, if you look at every manufacturer, their
beginner wings have a lower aspect ratio than their high
performance wings. There's very, I can't think of
any manufacturer that kind of, you know, that the ENB has a
higher aspect ratio than their ENC.
It just doesn't really happen unless there's some specialist
mounting wings or something. Aspect ratio is the most
important factor in very turbulent air.
When the wing, when the when you're in really turbulent air
and the wing is making shapes and moving in pitch and loses
its span cohesion, aspect ratio takes over.
And that's why comp wings are a bit more demand, more demand to
fly than E&D wings and E&D wings are more than E&C.
When we get down to E&B, we're getting into a realms where we
current knowledge and technology, well, not
technology, but current knowledge.
I'd say we're struggling. We, we, we can't make super low
aspect ratio with two lines and still support the whole
structure very well. You know something's going to
give you, you either have to have a massive gap between the,
the A's and the B's, in which case it will be hard to control
the, the the cord unless we start bugging in a load of
carbon or something. And if you have a big gap
between the, the bees and the trailing edge, then you just got
this big floppy unsupported thing at the back of the wing,
which will give you horrible structure and vague breaks that
won't be very nice to fly. So aspect ratio limits where we
can go with two liners at the moment, unless you start bugging
in a load of rigid structure in the wing.
But another factor as well for me and the big the big point for
me, because we did have collapse lines in E and BA few years ago,
but that was banned. What's nice about E&B is a is a
is a place for up and coming pilots to, to to go to is a.
You can have the most exquisite handling.
The best tightest turning turning radius is probably on a
high performance E&B wing. A good pilot on a on a the A&B
wing will be able to turn inside anyone or a comp wing.
So your climb rate can be amazing.
The handling is really fun. They're like the Porsche 9/11 of
our of our flying machines. So it's actually a really cool
place for relatively experienced.
When I say that, I mean you'd need to have like 100 hours to
be flying a top end high end B at least and maybe done an SIV
course. But you find a real sweet spot
in in in pure flying pleasure with the E&B wings.
And with that wing you can then progress on to doing cross
country acro SIV. You can really learn your trade
on these high end E&B wings and that gives you in good stead if
you choose because many pilots choose not to go beyond that
point. But if you really want to get
into more performance and do more cross country, that's when
it gives you a good stepping stone into the next level of
wing up. So I think right now we're in
the best position that we've ever been.
When I think about back in the years of what the products that
we had throughout all the different ranges for all the
different pilots, I think right now looking at the range that
Ozone have and looking at the range that other manufacturers
have, it's a really good time to be a pilot because you've got
such a good choice of different wings from different
manufacturers and there's no, there's no real dogs out there
anymore. So it's all good.
It's all healthy, I think. Totally agree.
And I think with the with this discussion, we answered the
question more or less about how to upgrade from a 2 1/2 or three
liner E&B to A2 liner C for any pilot who is wandering out
there, You know, because like, yeah, as long as stepping on the
stepping stone feels comfortable and you've done your homework,
just like, yeah, feel free to explore the more exciting world,
I would say, which is not just more stable, but also more fun
and expands your flight envelope by a whole lot further.
Yeah, I think, you know, we got a lot of feedback at Ozone.
I get quite a lot of the feedback at Ozone and a lot of
people who were really concerned about the photon, for example,
when we released that were pleasantly surprised.
Everyone was I had no feedback saying, OK, yeah, this is too
much for me. I I want to go back to its four
liner Enci don't recall any anything like that.
The vast majority of the feedback that we had was, was
really positive in, in terms of how comfortable people are, how
intuitive it was to fly 2 liners, how easy it was.
And they wish they'd made that step earlier.
And the same thing when we released, we when we recently
released the Delta last year, which was the lower aspect, the
NC, we again, there was a lot of die hard Delta pilots that were
a little bit wrecked. They were like, what do you mean
you've changed it to A2 liner? You've ruined my Delta
experience. And pretty much every one of
them have come back to me and said wow, this is amazing, this
is brilliant. This is way better than all the
other deltas that I've had. And so I think once you kind of,
you know this, there's a lot of and I understand why and because
the early days, the first generation of two liners were,
were difficult, They were demanding and we haven't quite
worked it all out. And they were unpleasant.
They had some unpleasant behaviour and were difficult to
fly and that gave 2 liners a bad reputation, a bad Rep over the
years. Whereas now with the
understanding that we've had, we've had two liners have been
around 16 years now and in that time the designers have, have
have learnt to make them much better.
And, and, and part of the testing process as well.
We understand the behaviour a little bit better to a point now
where if you, if you blindfold me and I had to do a full stall
or a spin, I wouldn't know if it's a 2 liner or a three liner.
If you, if, if you, if someone else collapsed it.
For me, I'm not. Obviously I can feel what I'm
collapsing in my hands, but if someone collapsed I can't tell
the difference between a collapse on A2 liner or three
liner given if everything else was the same.
There is no difference in behaviour.
I've come to the conclusion with with the modern generation of of
two liners. Wow, I I've always had this
notion that two liners just went like less often, but they when
they did they was they just went a lot more harder.
But that's such a relief to hear now.
No, I don't think that's the case.
No, we the wings that went the hardest with the old fashioned
comp wings, they, they, they used to go horrible paragliders
throughout over the years have gone bad.
You know, what tends to happen though, when you do have a wing
that's more inherently stable is that it is the really hard
turbulence that collapses them. And so when you do get the
collapse, it's normally because of very aggressive hard
turbulence and you go, oh, that goes harder than the old ones
used to. But the old ones used to be
going in all turbulence and would go equally and hard in
that same given turbulence. So you do get less collapses,
which is why you can become, you know, a little bit less practice
that those collapses and the collapses do come a little bit
stronger because it's the stronger air that's making them
elapse that way. But old high, high CM wings
would would collapse equally bad in those conditions.
Reserve deployments whether or not the the coefficient, moment
coefficient, the reflex, the amount of reflex in the way.
Right, there's a lot of technical jargon which like
layman does not understand. What's so interesting?
Hearing a professional talk about it like that.
Yeah. Well, like I was saying, like I
was saying earlier, we went from, you know, very lifty
profiles that we had negative CM.
So they, their tendency is nose down and we're now going towards
more reflex type profiles, which has a nose up tendency in, in,
in its movement, which which makes the wings more inherently
stable, but it does make them more difficult to get through
certification. But, but going back to the two
liner, I, I, I really strongly believe that with the latest
generation and I can only really talk about the wins that we've
made and the wins I've personally developed.
But I think we got to a point there where the difference in
behaviour between two line or three line has has merged into
insignificance. And in terms of safety, I see
the two liner for the right pilot for an experienced pilot
as an easier more comfortable winter for.
I remember you were like you know earlier a few, a few like
moments ago you said that it's quite an amazing time to be a
paraglider pilot with the amount of offerings that are there in
the industry. The question comes to my mind,
is your generation one of the only ones who has seen the most
amount of development in our industry?
Because you guys have seen it from absolute chaos to, I
wouldn't say butter smooth, but like we're in, I don't know,
like that's a lot of evolution that has gone down in two or
three decades where you started flying and now you're like, you
know. Yeah, I mean that, I mean,
paragliding only really existed in the mid 80s, didn't it, with
people jumping off with parachutes.
And then it's developed into what we have today.
And you know, that's, I think it's, it's down to, like you
said, the minority pushing it. You know, when the when the SAT
theme came on the on the on the scene and they were pushing acro
and that was a period when everyone said do acro, you know,
the old pilots and the old pilots and all of that nonsense.
And and then those boys came and I would just robbed it and all
the old school were like, they'll die quickly.
And they didn't. And they pushed the foot, the
sport forward. They, they showed what was
possible with those old comp wings and they created the whole
acro scene, which is narrowing into an acro world tour and
people doing tricks that I can't even imagine.
And look at the comp scene now. You know, from, from I remember
the first comp scene I used to do be like, all I'd worry about
was don't land at the bottom of the hill, you know, don't land
at the bottom. And a good day is when you
didn't land at the bottom, whereas now I don't even think
about landing at the bottom. And we're, we're, we're doing
the amazing flying. In fact, flooring has become in
the mountains. Racing paragliders for me in the
mountains has become. Boring is not the right word,
but just way too predictable. It's way too linear.
It's like, OK, we're flying in the mountains.
I go there, I fly along that at full speed.
I do three or four turns in a climb across the valley.
I go along there at full speed. I do that ad infinitum until the
end of the race and it's not as interesting as it used to be.
There's a beautiful old film on VHS of Robbie Whittle doing the
the World Championships in, in Sant Andre back in 1749.
I think it was, I don't know what year it was.
It was, it was years ago and he was talking about having to
climb and make a move, special move just to do something that
nowadays you just glide over and land.
We, the performance has given us has taken away a little bit of
the, the tactical element in racing paragliders in the
mountains, which is why for me right now I'm only really
interested in flatland flying. My my interest in mountain
flying, well, especially mountain racing is diminishing
because it it lacks, it lacks a great deal of tactical element.
I have a suggestion. So, you know, going back to it,
yeah, we're in a great place. We've got acro, we've got
parakites, which are another world, mini wings, some of the
mini wing flying that I watched the those doing loops down those
gullies and stuff. Yeah, I think we're in the
golden era, aren't we? I think I think we'll look back
as old men. So yeah, that that's the golden
area era. But hopefully better things are
going to come. Hopefully better things are
going to come. I was going to quip in with the
suggestion that if your romance has changed from chasing
mountain thermals to flatland then you might consider moving
to beer because that is one place which offers it all.
You know, got the mightiest of the ranges and then fair bit of
flatlands in front so and good food you know.
Don't forget that. I, I've been to beer and I
scared myself on beer and I'm, I scared myself by going over the
bat and I was quickly in an area of where I felt so overwhelmed,
so small. And so I'll equipped to deal
with having to land in those conditions.
You know, in fact, I actually got properly scared one of the
last times I got properly scared in the air flying in those
mountains. I have a deep respect for those
big mountains and a lack of mountaineering ability.
So I always feel, I always feel like I'm, I shouldn't be there.
Every time I was there, I, I felt like I shouldn't be there.
Oh. Damn, that's deep.
Well, you can only do what you're what you're equipped to
do with. You know what, if you're flying
in big, big mountains with no roads, no landings, you better
be a Mountaineer, you know, toy, you know, Johnny Sylvan, Johnny
Sylvan, those guys that, that, that forged those routes and
Antoine Jabbar and the guys that are doing that, they know what
they're doing. You know, they've got the skills
to be able to deal with it going wrong.
They, they've got the skills to be able to get them off a
crevasse, get them off a, get them off a, you know, a glacier
or something. I, I'm from Croydon.
I I don't have those skills. This know thyself.
Know thyself as better as you can, Russ.
But you know what? I was going to say that this
episode is like giving me goosebumps in a figurative way,
because figurative matter because I I have delayed like
for the audience members to just to let them know I I've wanted
to have Russ on the show since the beginning of me starting
paragliding Atlas and then something in me just said that,
you know, wait until you're worthy of having someone of his
teacher. And now I finally felt ready to
do invite you and stuff. And I'm I'm so glad the way we
are having this conversation, like everything feels like in a
flow, at least for me as a host, because there were a bunch of
topics that I've listed and to be honest, I was a bit nervous
before going in. I was like, how am I going to
make them sound natural and how I'm going to talk upon them
without stammering or, you know, without kind of hitting a
roadblock. But the way all the previous
episodes have kind of come together as well.
And you know, the latest one being you mentioning the, the,
the acro team, like we even had Raul Rodriguez on the show back
in the day. So like we have been mentioning
of all of these pilots that we have had.
And I, I think I'm going to make a list of all of these mentions
in the show notes. So anybody who's listening to
this gem of a production can refer back to them and like, you
know, absorb all the awesomeness that you guys create.
Well, one thing that I, I missed out on and I was kind of finding
it hard to know where to start that because like, of course,
you know, we are way beyond the time that, and you're very kind
to not mention it. But the, the, the thing that I
was kind of curious was about energies.
I'm a firm believer that places have energies.
I'll, I'll, I'll explain it in, in, in a certain context that,
for example, you go to a rave, a forest rave, that place has
energy. There's a bunch of people
chasing the same goal, the same, you know, mindset in the same
zone. You go to a temple, you go to a
place of worship. That place has its own energy.
Does gaggle also have energy? Like you said, beer, You know,
you, you felt a very like inner voice saying that yes, this is
how you should be feeling right now.
So I believe flying has a lot of energy.
Do you have something to say on that?
It's the it's the beautiful game.
There's nothing more beautiful than racing cross country with
your friends and racing together.
And it's something that I think it will all of all of the, the
race that the competition community understand and, and
and get and you know from, from all the other sports I've ever
done, which I've thoroughly enjoyed.
Nothing can nothing can touch racing a paraglider.
It's and I've always called it the beautiful game.
It's it's for me, it's so involving and it's it's pure
escapism. It's just escapism on the on on
the highest level really. And, but you're doing it with
friends and you're all trying to achieve the same thing.
And you have a, a purpose, a flight with purpose.
I think as you, when, when you're, when you're young in
your flying career, you can just fly for the sake of flying.
And many people only ever fly for the sake of flying.
And that's great. That's fine.
I, I can't do that anymore. Like the only flying I, I, I
really enjoy is developing wins or racing.
I, I don't go just flying at the weekend for myself.
So to me, that's, well, it's kind of pointless because I have
a family and and I'd fly every day during the week.
So. But no, paragliding is
paragliding. Racing is a beautiful game.
I don't think, you know, when you look at Formula One driving
or something, I mean, they're, yeah.
I mean, I know that they're superstars and they're well paid
and what they do and they're very good at what they do.
But I wouldn't want to do that every day, you know, just be
boring going around the same track time and time again,
trying to take off 4 eighths of a second somewhere or I don't
know. To me, it's as soon as you get
over the excitement of the, the speed and the, and the racing,
it, it becomes a little bit samey.
Whereas Paraguarding it's, it's always different and it always
gives you something new And it, it is just a beautiful game.
And, and we're also it's cool to be part of a really beautiful
community as well. We have good evening mostly.
Community, I think that is what makes it fabulous and something
out of the world because you have to be a bit of like an
extraordinary person to chase such amazing feats super high up
as a human, see that point of view and make sense of it to do
it repeatedly. And for for those of us who get
a chance to make a life out of it, like holy freaking moly man,
can you get any more lucky than out of the 8 billion rolling
this planet? Baffles my mind.
Yeah, no, I, I, yeah, you're right.
And it's something I've always been very aware of and very
grateful for. And especially, you know, to be
born in a, in, in this period of history, you know, our
grandparents couldn't have done it.
And it's possible our grandchildren won't be able to
do it. So I think we're we're very,
very blessed to get to be where we are.
Ross, I did not like, OK, I I did like think about this
before, but if you allow me, can I speak about Kiwi Johnson
respectfully, if you if that's OK with you.
Absolutely. Yeah, of course.
I, I heard in Gavin's show, I do not remember what World Cup it
was, but I, I do clearly remember that you were flying
with his logo on your wing as a tribute.
And I, or maybe this was jockey saying, I think he was your team
leader at that time and he was giving you some radio
instructions at that time. And your final glide was was
almost impossible to be to be made, but you still somehow did
make it and you won. Can you tell a little bit more
about that, that flight? I'm very fascinated about it.
Yeah, that flight, yeah. I think in the notes you said
you've got to think of a of a special flight.
And I've had so many flights so it's really hard to pin one
down, but that probably has to be the one.
So Kiwi had an I do the logo rings at Ozone.
I saw out on wings and I've known Kiwi for years, a good
mate of mine and his third eye logo, which was his big wings
and a little sky angler. I think we've made that wing for
him and he wanted to go. His plan was to fight for New
Zealand at the World Championships and unfortunately
he passed away. He before he got the opportunity
to do that. So when we went to the World
Championships in, in Argentina, I, I, I just got a replica made
in my side. He is an extra large.
I, I, I took my normal medium size and had a replica made and
I took it to the world to represent Kiwi at the World
Championships, the one that he wanted to go to but couldn't go
to. And that particular flight was
from a, from a sporting perspective, it was one of my
worst ever performances. I, I, I got stuck at the start.
People were going down. It was a difficult day, like 30
or 40 people landed before the start and I managed to hang on
with my fingernails but lost the whole race.
The league gaggle went, were out of sight.
They were long gone and I just managed to eventually get up and
bimble my way around the task. And suddenly, but we got into
this really good cycle with me and a couple of pilots and we
got up, finally got to cloud base.
It's amazing. And we, we flew over the top of
the lead gaggle and it was only by our pure, well, certainly by
my pure incompetence for the rest of the earlier part of the
day that I'd got myself in this situation.
Had I actually been doing the right thing and being on
programme, I'd have been down there with the league Daggle.
But it just happened that we we're able to fly over them.
And I got away from those couple of pilots and I had AI had 10K
with 12:50 on a grey day with very light winds slightly up my
backside. So for me it was a no brainer.
And I left, I left the thermal, it wasn't particularly strong
thermal, but it was like, well, I'm high enough 10 to 110 K here
we go. And with 5K to go, there was, I
was, I was desperately looking for the, the landing field and I
just couldn't see it. And then and then eventually
it's like all it's, it's, it's really high up in your field
vision. It's like there's no chance I'm
going to glide there. But somehow, and I'm not, I'm
not a Mystic, but I put it down to Kiwi actually, I think he was
on my shoulder that day because somehow I just managed to to
pull off this impossible glide. And I just kept going, kept
going, kept going. And, and even with with 100
meters to go, it looked like I wasn't going to cross the line.
And I just got a little BLOB of lift about 10 meters, 15 meters
off the ground, which just gave me enough height to to clear the
goal line and and cruise in. So it was an amazing, amazing.
I was just struck with sheer disbelief that I managed to get
into goal that day and I managed to win the task by like 15
minutes or something. So it was, it was the most
important task for me to probably see all that World
Championships. And I think I had Kiwi on my
shoulder the whole way. Yeah.
And it was great to do it under his wing as well.
I still, I don't own any wing, but I still have that wing on a
shelf and I've never taken it out of the bag again since the
last day. It's covered in champagne and I
folded it away covered in champagne and it hasn't been
unfolded since. But it's it's definitely a wing
that I'll that is a is a keeper for me.
I like could not have like, you know, there's there's no better
tribute than that and talking about energies, yes man, that's
like nothing but special good energies coming your way.
That's. Yeah, well, that was Kiwi for
me. Kiwi was, you know, it was good
friend and one of the the very special.
You go through life and you meet some special people.
And for me personally, Kiwi was was one of them.
And I think you know what happened again.
And Bill was a really big part of the success of the
recruitment finding him and the amount of people that Kiwi
touched in his life, I think was testament to the man that he
was. You know, he had friends in many
different circles. And so many people came out to,
to celebrate Kiwi as a, as a given beer.
And I think that's just testament to the man that he
was. I think he just touched my show
with his presence, so he's still making the positive impact.
Wow, that's such a good. Honour yeah.
I mean, if you just need to go back and you just need to go
back and read some of the stuff that he wrote, he's a fantastic
writer and he's written loads of good books as well.
And definitely worth checking it out.
I can, I can take some links and put them in the show notes for
anybody in the audience who's curious because, yeah, I wasn't
a podcaster back then. But I think this is one way that
I can be a part of that legacy in one way or the other for the
future generations to refer back to.
Russ, I'm lost for words. There's no one single episode
that can do justice to a pilot of your stature.
You know this is. I don't, I think, you know, I
think, yeah. I mean, there's we all just do
what we can do throughout life, you know, And I'm not a special
pilot in any way. I've just sort of dedicated my
life to it. I mean, good things have
happened to me. Fortunate doors have opened.
And I've always liked with fly, I take the path of least
resistance and things have worked out OK.
And and I think, you know, flying is, is is is such a
beautiful sport. It's taught, it teaches us so
many things. And I think we can all grow as
humans through flying. And I think the most, especially
in modern society where we always default and tend to blame
other people for things that happen, it's not their fault.
I think paragliding teaches you responsibility.
It's self responsibility. You're when you take off, when
you clip into your harness, responsibility, responsibility
comes down to you and nobody else.
And it's, we're fortunate, you know, to be able to, to have
that responsibility in certainly in the Western society, we're,
we're, we're so wrapped in cotton wool, especially the way
we bring up our kids these days. And it's something I've done
with my kids. I've wrapped my kids in more
cotton wool, like, like everyone else.
But I've always insisted that they take responsibility for
their own actions. And when something happens, it's
their responsibility in one way or another.
And having ownership over responsibility, I think is, is
really important. And that's certainly one of the
biggest lessons that Paragon has taught me.
I think recognising that is such a special place to be where you
it's quite a blessing to be able to recognise that and then be
aware of it and I think you put it in.
Such a good, I mean, I mean, that's why, you know, there's,
there's yeah, we're we're free to go and kill ourselves, you
know, flying paragraphs. And that's there's a beauty in
that when, when we're in such a controlled society, but we're,
we're still free flying. And and that's what I love about
paragliding is that is the old is the old theory of free
flight. And just it's, it's not.
It is literally free flying. And, and that's why there was
that's the beauty of the open class.
That's the beauty of the the kind of no rules off you go is
free flying. And I hope we find the right
balance going forward with, you know, the, the, the, the rules
that are coming in for the sake of safety, for the sake of
fairness. I hope as we go forward that we
don't over focus on safety and over focus on fairness and means
the the core value of what free flying is, you know, you know,
hopefully we will have enough wisdom to be able to make the
right decisions collectively to go forward and make the sport
better. I think if the intent is good,
everything else falls into place and that is one thing that is.
Yeah, yeah. But the, you know, the road to
hell is paved with good intentions and if you go too
far, you can end up in a in a situation where the paragon
competitions become less attractive for the masses.
I think we just have to take it step by step and not be too
radical at this stage. Wasn't going to be, wasn't
preparing to ask this question, Russ.
But some things that we need to be careful of as a community, of
course, like rubbing each other off in in a wrong sense is
definitely one of them. But you know what are the major
things that will help us move forward as a unit rather than as
one man armies as we have done sometimes in the past?
I think it's, I think it's, I think it's exactly that.
It's recognizing that you know what, what is good for you
personally is not necessarily what's good for the whole sport.
And I think, you know, when the whole pilot union thing started
out, it seems to me just a lot of people shouting about what
was best for them. And, you know, like the the
equalizers debate really showed where, you know, all the little
people wanted the equalizers and all the big people didn't want
the equalizers, you know, and those in the middle were just
like, oh, I'm not sure. And so, yeah, I think, I think
it's about defining what's good for the sport, where we want to
go, how what we want to change and also understanding the
limitations. Like Bill was saying on your
show, you know, paragliding is dangerous and it and we can't
get away from that. We'll never get away from that.
There is an inherent danger to what we do.
It doesn't suffer mistakes. It doesn't doesn't suffer fools.
It doesn't suffer messing up your take off.
It doesn't suffer messing up your landing or pushing too low
round the corner that you don't know what's around there.
You know, it's, it always comes down to the decisions that we
make as pirates, which is probably not the most critical
factor than the equipment itself or the task setting or all the
other aspects that do play a role.
But they will never become more important than the decision
process that the pilot makes. So I think as long as we all go
forward thinking about what is best for the sport rather than
what's best for yourself personally, I think it's
probably the best way to to think about it.
And even throughout, you know, the debates, what I've what,
what shines through really is, even though there's some
disagreements and there's, there's, you know, some rather
nasty comments and, and the like, what shines through is, is
a, a sort of Verity that of what people believe is best for the
sport. So I think, I think we're in
good hands. I think, I think there's enough
good brains and big people to that care about our sport enough
to be able to to guide it in the right direction.
I think basically looking out for greater good than just self
good as the essence of finding success in life.
This thing was kind of a bit of an alien to me because
emigrating to a whole different ecosystem means that you are
more or less fending for yourself a lot of times.
There's no backup, there's no safety net, there's no there's
no team. You leave your team behind and
you're looking to build up a new team.
So the lone wolf theory is kind of applicable for a certain
stage, but then it's like being a lone wolf, no matter how
empowering or liberating or free will only get you so far and
eventually tribe is your way to go forward.
And that's why I kind of built up paragliding Atlas because I
was like, yes, I have my own goals and priorities that I want
to accomplish in the community. But somehow changing that
perspective to how can I serve the community just gave me
endless ideas and starting the show was one of them.
But even in the show, the question came back after
divulging into a certain topic and that's OK.
Now how do I find new topics? So I was like, OK, let's go back
to the same thought process that I had at the time of starting
the show that what does community want to know more?
So like the power of looking out for a greater good more than
yourself is so limitless, is so empowering that it has a chance
to create positive ripples which will be amplified.
And that is how the world goes around, in my opinion.
Totally. And, and you know, we're like
you say with the, you know, our sport is the, it's such an
individual sport. But what it does is it brings
together individually minded people who often can
collectively actually be very strong.
So we're, we're, we're, we're blessed to have a good
community. Russ, I want to close, but I
want to close on the topic of MBE because I think that is one
of the highest recognitions that a pilot has ever received in our
community. British Order of I didn't even
know what had existed until it it it was bestowed upon you.
Closing comments How did it happen and what is it?
We are. Well, I'll tell you a story
about an NBA. Is this, as my nephews called
it, a major Bell end? One more time.
Actually, he's a major bell end. Bell end.
I won't explain what bell ending.
I won't explain explain what Bell ending?
Seems like a British mantra. Google it up people.
Google it up. You'll find an answer which I do
it. Means a member of the British
Empire is what it means and it's a honour that's given by the
royal family to to individuals that are that that people apply
for. I, I was, I was at a super
final. I was at a super final in Mexico
a few years back and I, and just before taking off, I got a
telephone call from Sebastian Mark one calling on behalf of
King Charles the third or something like that, asking,
asking whether I would accept an MBA.
This was after winning the world championship.
And I was actually in two moments because because I'm,
I'm, I'm deeply republican, in my opinion, republican from a
British sense of being queen of anti royal family, which I had
been for my whole life. My father, my parents, they're,
they're absolute royal beasts. They love it.
So there was a there was a kind of moment where I was like, I
was really wanted to say no, but for my parents sake, I, I, I, I
accepted it. And that was that very same day,
that very same day in the World Cup.
I was I got the little lead. I got the little lead on
everyone just coming into the to goal and we still need it.
We had to go back to the three kings.
Those of you know, via the Bravo, we'll know the three
kings. We had to we were coming from
the flats in front. I just had to get one climb at
the three kings. Bang and I've won the task and I
even said to myself come on Ogden NBE.
I even said that to myself as I was pushing on to get the last
climb and I get to the 3 kings. I'm not in psycho and honour.
And the others came over a few minutes later and and and and
smoked me and I was so annoyed that I even left a bit low and
ended up landing in a tree. It was from hero to 0.
But the whole experience of the NBA was, was, was really good.
Yeah, we went, we went to Windsor Palace and I, I was, I
was given a, a, the we had to buy a suit and shoes and a tie
and everything. I had nothing like that.
And so it was. But it was a great day for the,
for the family and I, yeah, an honour, an honour to have.
But I'm not the first in the British paragliding community
because Judy Ledon was also MBA and I think there was another
pilot who also has an MBA and but yeah, no, it wasn't on that.
I mean, it's made my my parents very proud.
I can imagine. I'd like to everybody else who
flies as well, it's like the first thing is like the British
family follows paragliding that closely.
That's kind of cool. Well, I, I was, I was given it
by Princess Anne, who's the, the sister of the, the king.
And she, I think she must have been briefed because she was
really up to, to score on, on how the Brit team won the World
Championships and that we were in Argentina and all of these.
She was like, I was actually really impressed with the with
what she knew about paragliding, actually.
But yeah, I don't, I don't think any of them have ever done it.
Well, it's never too late to start.
Maybe you should tell them next time you get a chance to
interact. So but what was it?
Is it a scroll? Is it a medal?
Like how the how does the physical thing look like?
It's, it's a, it's a little medal, yeah.
It's a little medal, yeah. Fascinating.
Yeah, it was a silver. A silver medal, yeah.
Yeah. Great.
But it doesn't. It doesn't give me any.
It doesn't give me any benefits or anything like that.
It doesn't. Come on, Ross, you got bragging
rights for life. That's kind of cool.
Yeah, it's, it's actually not something I talk about, to be
honest. Some people write it after their
name and stuff. I I don't do any of.
That can I write it in the in the show title, you know?
Do you have to? Yeah, I love your house.
No, no, if. If I've got a choice then I'll
say no. Well, fair enough.
Now people know why I did not because I was so tempted.
It would look kind of cool. Cross country did, actually,
they they did, right? Russell didn't have.
To be Yeah, they did, Yeah. Yeah.
It helps with the Google. I I had to, I had to renew my,
you can actually put it on your passport and I had to renew my
passport recently and I was like, no, no, no, don't be a
prick. So I didn't, I didn't put it on
there. I mean, yeah, but like I was
going to say, like you haven't you been living in France long
enough to get a French passport? Are you still renewing the visas
after Brexit? Every now and.
Then no, we, we, we have our, we have our own permanent residency
here. My, my kids have dual
nationality. But well, it's me and my wife
are still British. Yeah, I mean, tell me about
visas. I go through the pain every
single year to survive in this side of the world, but it's kind
of fun. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Russ, as I said this has been beyond words.
A huge honour, pleasure and fascinating to have you on the
show. Long time coming but could not
have come at a better time. So you know from the bottom of
my heart, no matter how how much I want to keep going, I would
like let's call it a day for now and until next time, can't wait.
Yeah, yeah, yeah. Thank you very much.